My hope for the future
is to realise my full potential,
and understand
why I was put on this earth.
Hopefully, by the time I leave this world,
I will understand my true purpose in life.
My name's Patrick Cabral and I'm a multimedia artist.
Since childhood, I've always believed
in challenging myself.
It's important to pursue new things,
even if they seem impossible.
The first time I remember drawing was in Kindergarten.
I chose to draw the Leyte Landing -
it was super detailed.
When my teacher saw it,
she praised me in front of the class.
That sparked my passion for drawing.
You don't have to have raw talent to create something beautiful;
what artists need is support
from others to realise their full potential.
I grew up in a province where
people weren't that interested in art.
We didn't have museums or galleries,
so the only thing to fuel me
was my desire to succeed.
After years of practice, I finally found my unique style.
Papercutting was a skill I already had,
so I combined this with lettering and typography.
I set myself a challenge to create a design in paper using tiny detail.
I asked myself, "What's the thinnest line that I can create using paper?"
It wasn't easy,
but it helped me establish
the concept of my work.
The first papercut animal I made was a wolf.
It didn't involve much planning -I just wanted it to look nice!
Now that I'm a practising designer,
I aim for 50% concept, 50% execution.
Planning is important,
as it's where ideas grow.
It's through planning
that I wanted to show...
...parallels between my papercut animals
and our endangered species.
Both are fragile.
There's a quote I love:
"If you like a flower, you pluck it...
...if you love a flower,
you water it every day."
The same can be said for my craft.
Being an artist requires time,
patience, effort and daily practice.
Ideas are always forming - my work
will never cease to evolve.
At the moment,I'm known for my paper artwork,
but I want to develop and explore
the possibilities of craft in other ways.
Regardless of the medium,
I'll always approach my work
with the same level of tenacity and precision
that I've achieved in my paper art.